he is the head coach of liscombe
academy football and he is also
the head coach at elite 11 and he's also
one of my favorite people on the planet
he is trent dilfer here on the rich
housing show how are you trent
well i'll take that last bio intros my
favorite of the three
is that right the fact that i'm you're
one of your favorite people on the
planet
yes yes i'm usually one of people's most
hated people on the planet
what are you talking about trent come on
now come on now i'm just kidding
come on now um what's happening brother
it's good to chat with you it's good to
see you
um let's just start um macro here what
did
you know what went through your mind as
you watched tampa bay win the super bowl
trent from back in your day let's just
go that way
what did you think of when you saw that
were you please conflicted
super happy okay good to hear super
jacked uh
i was i really you know how i look at
the game i try to learn
through watching the game and i thought
it was a great exercise in learning how
much a team
can evolve and grow and get better zero
goes on
you know you go to your talk show i'm
guessing in weeks when was there bye
week
they got beat by new orleans was that
week nine i think no yeah and then
we were talking about it yesterday that
you know uh
i picked tampa to win it all before the
season and then
on game day morning i had an opportunity
to to mulligan
on thanksgiving and that was the weekend
they were seven and four going in to
take on the chiefs and i hopped off them
and then they had to buy the next week
and there's nothing wrong with that i
mean because they weren't great
they were talented but not great and
they did it hadn't fit yet you know it
hadn't clicked i don't think they knew
who they were
so i i watched it at that second half of
the season
just saying okay something happened over
the bye week there was a come to jesus
there was uh
tom brady finally opened his mouth and
said no this is the way we're going to
be great
you know going from talented to great
we're going to start doing the little
ugly boring monotonous things well we're
going to clean up some of our scheme
stuff we're going to kind of find our
identity and it was pretty amazing
watching them grow you know after that
point how
one they became much more stubborn with
the run game so you got to give the play
callers
a lot of credit because when you have
that those types of weapons it's hard to
call boring runs
it's hard to be patient getting two and
a half three and a half yards to carry
on first down
they started utilizing more tight ends
uh they added tight ends into protection
so where they were five six man
protections they became
six seven man protection so adding an
extra guy
into protection brady all of a sudden
you saw
his normal calmness come back in the
pocket which you didn't see
in the new orleans game early on in the
year uh and then
even further than that than what they do
off those boring things they actually
became very very creative they kind of
found this
new way of playing offensive football uh
in
off board having really cool sizzly
plays off really boring stuff
so they sucker you with the boring stuff
and then they flash and sizzle you with
the explosive stuff
and while all this is going on they
are growing as a defense sure and
they're becoming nastier nastier
stronger healthier at the end getting
some of their big guys back up front
playing more snaps that the young
linebacker white's playing as good as
anybody else their veteran linebackers
are playing good
secondary they start growing they start
playing more stuff
what they did to green bay is one of the
great secondary
game plans i've seen in a long time uh
and they just evolved and i guess
long-winded way of saying i really
appreciated the nfl
in the midst of the craziest year of all
of our lives no
otas really no training camp
that they took the long tail approach
and to win a super bowl they said hey we
gotta
not flinch when bad things happen use
them as learning lessons
grow and make sure we're getting better
every single day and with this group of
people and with the greatest players
ever played
by the end we should be able to finish
this race and you more than anybody know
how difficult it is to get to a super
bowl and win it and what it means to
actually win it and what it means for
your resume seven is insane
and the fact that he we can sit here and
say eight is absolutely in the realm of
possibility if not
uh more likely than than not is insane
it's insane i just keep coming with
arbitrary numbers i'm like yeah he's won
13 super bowls
and nobody flinches or yeah he might win
20. and nobody really
just makes having fun with it like it's
it's mind-boggling
you can't process you can't really
comprehend what an incredible
achievement this is
and you've been for tom brady and do you
think it's messing with the heads of
others
um like rogers what he said after the
championship game
uh about wondering about his future
because he saw brady
walk into a new team do it his way or or
know that there's a way other than the
one that he's only known russell wilson
sitting here saying what he's thinking
thinking what he's thinking do you think
it's messed with other quarterbacks
brains what brady's done he's messed
with every i think he's messed with
everybody in the nfl's brains
i think he's messed with gm's that have
done great jobs and never won one
i think it messes with coaches to think
their process is as good as anybody's
and it and they haven't won one i think
it messes with guys that have won
one but think they were gonna one win
three or four
i think it makes the league knee jerk
react i'd say that
i think that's the greatest impact tom
brady's seven super bowls now have is it
makes the rest of the
league knee jerk react and make
decisions that probably aren't long tail
decisions
because they just they don't understand
it and i don't think any i think anybody
says they understand how he's done this
is
showing their ignorance in that
statement i don't think any of us know
how he's done
this because it's never been done before
i think there's one person that knows
how he's done this and his name's tom
brady
and maybe his dad because he tells the
dad everything yes that's right
that's the keeper of the secrets i've
got uh super bowl champion and let's go
academy football head coach elite 11
football
uh head coach trent dilfer here on the
rich eisen show while we're on the
subject of knee-jerk reactions i'm sure
you have heard the narrative that justin
herbert's better than touhou
and that that's the way it should have
been viewed by everyone in the draft and
that's the way it's only gonna be
and i know you're a too a guy so i'll
give you the floor and you're laughing
already but that is it that is
i am not stuttering when i am saying
that as a significant
narrative that is bouncing around the
nfl and its media right now
well i think it's true right now but
does it matter right now
does it matter right now that justin
herbert joa and boro all lost a bunch of
games
because really the things about winning
or losing now who throws the most
yards looks the best who wins rookie of
the year like right now absolutely
justin herbert was fantastic i argue
he's one of the best rookies we've seen
in the last 20 years play quarterback
peyton manning through 20 interceptions
as rookie here
how many of us thought after peyton's
rookie year oh he's staying c
through 20 interceptions he's never
going to fix this
i hasselbeck and i used to watch
peyton's rookie film
when we're just studying offense mech
ooh he's got a lot of learning to do
like ooh we're not sure about this guy
this is peyton manning
he's one of the greatest of all time so
let's let this thing breathe for a few
years let's let their teams figure out
who they are
let's see what they're surrounded with
now you know
justin's got to go through a new head
coach new offensive system let's see how
that goes
what really matters who's the best in
three or four years and who has a chance
to take their team to super bowl on the
first contract because that's really now
the new
measuring stick for these young
quarterbacks is while you are
cheap can your team use those assets
use that money they're eventually gonna
have to pay you to pay others
to help you get to the super bowl and
are you good enough if we surround you
with enough good people
to take you to us to allow you to take
us to a super bowl
so russell wilson like you gotta go now
if you're if you're one of these rookie
top picks your goal
is before i get my next contract i need
to get my team to a super bowl because
they're taking all this money
that they're eventually going to pay me
and they're getting to the left tackle
the the kind of the extra receiver that
you really don't need
but you could have uh that third
safety player that third secondary
player that you really don't need but
you can pay and now you have more depth
that the davion county presence and free
agency that's going to demand a big
number but it's a game record jj watt
is another example of that going to
arizona like can you take us to a super
bowl while you're cheap
let's wait and see who does that between
borough herbert tua
before we get on our soapbox and saying
oh yeah we should have had him higher
and by the way i'd also challenge all
those guys because i was on all the same
shows as them yours being one of them
is if they were so right did why didn't
they have number one on the board
like listen this thing is fluid uh all
three were really good prospects and i
think the guys i respect the most the
daniel jeremiah's the guys like that
that's how they presented it
is great prospects let's see where they
fit
let's see what organizations they go to
let's see who they're surrounded by
you know let's see their circumstances
before we start saying who's going to be
the best they have different trait
like joe burrows not as talented as tua
and herbert but he processes faster
herbert has more horsepower and twitch
than both of them it paid off his first
year let's see how as this thing grows
it goes two it has the best instincts of
the three he didn't really get to use
those instincts the first year maybe now
he's in a system
that unleashes him a little bit more i
don't know but let's at least
let's just think let's let this thing
play out so then what would you counsel
to
or have uh about year two
um while he also no doubt goes through
the conversation that darnold is hearing
which is like
boy we we well donald i think it's heard
a ton of stuff
but uh we'll we'll we'll send you to
houston if the texans
eventually decide watson doesn't really
want to play for them anymore i mean
what would you counsel too it was no
doubt hearing all of that out of
dolphins fence
i'd imagine same thing at council a 17
year old that's frustrated they only
caught four balls instead of 10
because he's an all-state wide receiver
trust the process
handle the process well take care of
your business control what you can
control
you can't control that coach dofer
called a terrible game in the state
championship game
that's not your fault you did your job
when you're asked to do your job
the rest is on coach stilfer so tua
can't control what the organization does
he can't control who they draft if he
ends up staying there he can't control
if they drop big guys
on the defense side of the ball or
twitchy fast guys of office on the ball
he can control his process he can be
grinding in the off-season
he can look at his tape and say oh this
is something i didn't do very good
i got to get better at this and go to
work at it he can look at his tape and
say
i did this pretty well i'm going to pat
myself on the back and say i'm going to
build off of this these are some
positives
but if you don't take a process driven
approach to this thing and you start
worrying about all the things you can
control
yeah he'll end up the worst is worse of
the three but if he
handles his business well and continues
to do
his thing the best he can do it and
control what he can control
good things will happen trentil for a
few more minutes left with him here on
the rich eisen show uh
what do you think the jets should do and
that's kind of a way that i can
throw everything in together how you
evaluate the quarterback class with zach
wilson and what you think of
darnold and knowing the scheme that
robert sala's bringing in and
uh what options there might be available
to other teams to go get donald what his
fit might be best i just throw that out
as an omnibus through the concept of
what you think the jets should do
right here i think number one sam wins
regardless
i think that he either stays with the
jets and they get better
uh and they use their draft capital to
get him some talent finally uh or
they choose to take one of these young
bucks and move on
from sam and he goes somewhere it's
going to value his skill set now
everything i'm hearing and i'm not
nearly as deeply entrenched as i used to
be so
the people i'm trusting tell me that
this narrative is actually
flipped on sam from underachiever to
over a cheaper
concerning what he's been dealing with i
think sam
is very well looked upon amongst nfl
circles
and how he's handled his business how
he's controlled what he could control
how he his ceiling his high ceiling
plays that he showed the ability to make
and is correcting some of the
knucklehead stuff he did his first year
i think all that goes over really well
with nfl teams that would rather have a
seasoned vet
than draft a new new guy so i think he
wins overall he's also starting to stack
up his reps
this is a conversation that when you
talk to other people talking
quarterbacks from here on out start
asking this question
how many starts how many reps being the
quarterback have they had
from high school to college and now in
the nfl
trevor lawrence to me is a no-brainer
will guarantee be successful
much like andrew luck because he started
four years in college
he's playing four years in high school
three years in college he's won
well how many games has he won i think
it's in the hundreds between the two
well we know how much very it's about to
say we only know how much he's lost
which means he's won a lot
if you can tell so many people a lot of
opportunities of being the quarterback
and the quarterback's more than just
taking the snap in the game it's
practice
it's locker room moral authority it's
being that person living the bigness of
the quarterback's life
off the field so it's a lot of stuff so
sam's now just catching up with that
remember we found sam for the elite
eleven
we had a broken ankle after his junior
year playing basketball
so we found him off as basketball tape
he hardly played any quarterback in high
school he plays very few
he starts very few games in college so
he's just getting that
quarterback rep count to where the best
stuff is going to come out
and i think people are starting to
understand that stuff it's one of the
questions around trey i think trey lance
is the second most talented well him and
fields i think have equal talent in the
draft i think he's wildly talented
i think he if he's handled properly will
be a massive success in this draft
very few times being the quarterback so
you're gonna have to make sure he gets
those reps he needs to take almost every
preseason rep
for probably two years he needs to sit
and watch he needs to get the reps in
the classroom in practice
but don't expect trey lance to step on
the field they want to be successful
because this has
less times being the quarterback than
trevor lawrence or justin fields
or wilson or i guess mack jones would
fit into that as well as a guy with
limited reps just one year sardi
so zach wilson though would be the guy
for at second overall that was what
pretty much everybody is thinking right
now and i guess dovetailing to put a
button on this entire conversation back
to what you said
moments ago about the key is to draft
the right guy high up and win a
championship while he's cheap and you
can pay everyone else around him
to support him and then make enough uh
of the
of the uh success uh to afford the next
contract right
so would you start from scratch with
zach wilson or rehabilitate sam darnold
that's the joe douglas question
unless again desean watson drops out of
the sky for a way that the jets feel is
is amenable what do you think yeah i
think he's framed that well you have
jason watson becomes available
every team that doesn't have tom brady
or aaron rodgers or patrick mahomes
should jump at that uh i think i would
go
keeping darnold i think he's earned the
equity within the organization the city
i think it's tough to earn people's
respect
in new york i think he's done that for
the most part you could tell me
otherwise
but i know a lot of jets fans that the
first year two years like oh no
did it wrong again and now watch him
compete and grind and
have resolve and grit and understanding
how bad they were
are like oh okay this guy's around with
talent he's our guy
so i could i could for that reason he's
earned the the
respect and equity of the fan base and
organization
uh and then i'm not sold listen i like
zach wilson so i'm not going to say
anything bad about him um
i don't think i think this he's the
guaranteed second thing is a little bit
of a hog wash
i think you have you're watching fields
there's a narrative going around
everybody's everybody's using the media
in the cyber warfare world where they're
launching mis messaging i think people
that i've talked to that i really
respect and do this a long time
really like fields the more they watch
them the more they realize how gifted
the pastor he is
i think mac jones has surprised some
people because they love him as the
passer they know he has no second
reaction stuff
i think there's teams that aren't quite
totally sold on the fact that wilson
wasn't a core captain
after being there for three years he was
a game day captain in our core cap and
they have eight core captains
and he's not one of them after being the
quarterback for three years i personally
have never heard of that before
so i think this is still early there's a
lot of false narratives out there
and i wouldn't be surprised if this
comes off the board after lawrence a
little bit different than people are
saying right now
trent dilfer look for my call in april
you're the man appreciate the time
truly you're you're the best rich right
back at you that's trent till for right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here